walk him to this video and playing panic
Grandmaster panic I don't know who that
is his doesn't have so many games played
27 84 85 so this is amongst the highest
rated ratings that I have ever saw here
so proudly am a world-class Grandmaster
I'm just speculating you don't you never
know okay I'm playing the Queens gambit
declined with Bishop e7 the variation
very often associated with the FM Geller
it's not just an inn it's not only
Geller who popularized that but he is
often cited in connection to the line
with night with Bishop to e7 ok what he
played with night g3 and all this I
consider to be one of the best lines so
not surprisingly he knows what he's
doing ok let's see me not a 6 had the
idea to play night c 76 and maybe in
some circumstances some circumstances to
play night before and is this such a
position where i should play night
before don't know i'd like to play
Bishop f8 to improve my defense here
already can play Bishop h6 in here takes
Knight takes King g7
that's a strange move
wow I didn't expect that at all what
what is happening here f6 he takes well
LH six when f6 is an ugly more I do I
know okay anyway yeah this is a
strategically an uncomfortable position
but still
hmm night yeah come on it says should
use this opportunity to get this night
out maybe Tweety for you a 494 yes yeah
I wonder if I take if he can I mean if I
take with the pawn will you check here
it's maybe a bad end game yeah is a bad
end game taking with rock salt some up
too attractive
ok I'm not sure how bad this is so let's
check check this is the end game I was
referring to and I have this idea night
33 maybe you should have played a 3 I
don't know i don't think the shirt
should be too bad for me
look to be six and isn't this good for
black would be six and a five if he
protected I mean if he advances before
hmm
Bishop takes this b6 I didn't see that
one I just played this in precise I
really I had him on the ropes this was
just good for black I know he escaped
yeah that it's even it's even already
tricky for me sheet to 785
hmm this is surprising why does he allow
this group to see 60 s see just
attacking with g5 or something
you know maybe this is Nakamura who just
wants to win on time but I don't know
just playing any booth as this wasn't a
blunder you check here did this on
purpose so i need to to use them i use
the king
96 killing time boarding
check
check
check yeah yeah it's just what every
time is a factor I mean a completely
outplayed him like two times but it was
just too slowly done very very very
frustrating around here he is completely
completely done I just need to play one
or two precise moves yeah like this one
okay six might write resigns he just
played this so badly getting letting me
into d3 Whitehead good control before
that no I would just win this pawn I had
forgotten about Bishop d7 after that
it's probably still okay but Luke a six
is just running the game he just loses
the queenside for no compensation and I
was some pretty good in pretty good
shape timewise at this at this point and
here it was was getting getting tricky
already yeah but him he played very bad
moves again f4 is just just terrible of
course you need to take on your form
very obvious actually now he's in
trouble again and he felt compelled to
give up that and the society was
completely lost just a matter of of the
time so what is the easiest yeah Bishop
to f8 is the easiest yeah getting the
special back I can do that in 37 seconds
but I was a bit too knows maybe this is
the easiest just um just okay this is
this is not bad but I should just go
back here this is this is good just
protecting this and then advancing with
the King and there's also look-see for
winning the spawns it's a very easy win
the computers and minus 6
it's not like in exchange it's just dead
lost but I didn't have any time yeah a
bit of a shame I mean he really did
everything to give away the game
especially moves like f4 just very very
bad I mean why not take this is just
much better and that quite obviously
better I don't understand it the thing
is after Luke takes my knight doesn't
have any squares so this is good for
white and I need to take with the porn
obviously and this is just a good
transformation you exchange your f pawn
against the deep own and now you can
just play on you have to deport and
white is better this is why me allowing
this configuration was bad through gate
6 was just just a much better and
clearer now it just winds the pawns and
the game alright but it was interesting
thanks for watching